Let's say I have a line, let
me make it a straight line.
And the equation of that line,
since it's running in the
horizontal direction is
going to be y is equal
to some constant.
So let me write that.
So the equation of this line
right here is y is equal to k.
And let's say I have
some other point.
I'll call that-- well, we'll
call that a focus because
it will be a focus.
And let's say that point--
let's put it right here-- is
it the coordinate, let's
call it a comma b.
And let's think about the set
of all points or the locus of
all points that are equidistant
to this point right
here and this line.
Just so you get the
terminology we'll call
this line a directrix.
Let me write that down.
Directrix, it's probably a word
you've never heard before.
And frankly, I've never heard
it outside of the context
of parabolas or conic
sections in general.
So let's call that a directrix.
This is our focus.
And what we want to do is we
want to find all of the points
in the xy-plane that are
equidistant to this focus
and this directrix.
So there's one point that just
by looking at it we could say
is going to be in our locus.
So it's going to be right there
because clearly, this point is
equidistant; it's halfway
between that point
and this line.
Now let's see what
other points.
There will probably be this
point right here because the
distance from there to there
is this name as the distance
from if you just drop
a line straight down.
Remember, we want to get the
shortest distance between
this point and the line.
We could have said something
like this distance, but this
distance wouldn't be the
shortest distance between
this point and this line.
So you would go straight
down to the line there.
Likewise, this point
would be there.
So that distance is the
same as that distance.
And you can already, I
think, begin to imagine
the type of shape this is.
And if you look at the title of
this video you can probably
guess where this is going.
That the shape is going to
look something like this.
Or something pretty similar to
what we know as a parabola.
And actually, it
will be a parabola.
There's no mystery there.
But what we're doing this in
this video is actually show
you that is a parabola.
Show it to you mathematically
instead of this
little drawing here.
Where I show you that it kind
of looks like it would be a
parabola because this distance
right here looks about the same
as that distance right there.
I could keep going up and down
the curve and keep doing that,
but that's not satisfactory.
Let's actually mathematically
show that the locus of all
points that are equidistant to
this point and this line-- this
focus and this directrix--
is in fact, a parabola.
So let's say I have some point
that's in this locus and let me
call the point here-- let me do
it in a different color because
it's the same color as
my directrix-- x, y.
So I want to find all of the x,
y's-- all of the points that
satisfy an equation where their
distance to the focus is equal
to their distance
to the directrix.
So what's the distance
between x, y and the focus?
What's this distance
right here?
d sub 1.
Well, we just used the
distance formula.
It's x minus the
x-coordinate of the focus.
So it's x minus a squared.
So the difference in
the x's squared.
Plus the difference in the y's
squared-- y minus b squared.
The square root of that.
So this is the distance
to the focus.
So I'll call that d sub 1.
That's this distance
right there.
And we want to find all of the
x and y's where the distance to
the focus is equal to
the distance to this
line right there.
So if we call this distance--
let's call this the d sub 2--
the distance to the directrix.
So the distance to the focus is
going to be equal to d sub 2.
And d sub 2, what's this
going to be equal to?
Well, it's just the difference
in y because no matter where we
are we're just going to drop
down straight to the directrix.
So the difference in y-- I
could just say y minus k.
That would be the
difference in y.
But in this case I did make it
so that the coordinate up here
is higher than the k over here.
But what if we had a situation
where this point was
below this line?
I mean, there's nothing here
that I said that we can only
deal with points
above this line.
We haven't proven that
to ourselves yet.
So to make sure that this
distance is positive we could
take the absolute value or
we could just square it and
then take the square root.
And then that ensures that
we're not dealing with
negative distances.
So here we set up the equation
for all of the x's and y's
where the distance to the focus
is equal to the distance
to the directrix.
And let's see if this actually
turns out to be a parabola.
So the first thing we can do is
we can square both sides and
get rid of the radicals.
So we get x minus a squared.
Radicals aren't good.
Well, I don't want to make
any social commentary.
So x minus a squared plus y
minus b squared is equal to
the square root of the other
side-- y minus k squared.
And right now, at least, it
looks like there's going to be
some y squared terms and I mean
there's definitely
an x squared term.
That doesn't seem like it's
a parabola right now.
But let's keep going forward.
This is x minus a squared.
And then let me square
these-- actually, expand
these two binomials.
So plus y squared minus 2yb
plus b squared is equal to y
squared minus 2yk
plus k squared.
Now what can we do
to simplify this?
Well, we have a y squared
here and we have a y squared
on the right-hand side.
So we can subtract y
squared from both
sides of the equation.
They cancel out, and then we
got rid of the y squared so all
of a sudden this is starting to
look a lot more like a parabola
because this is now an equation
that relates y's
to an x squared.
So let's clean this up and
actually make sure that we can
get it in a form that we
normally associate
with a parabola.
So we now have-- I'll just
rewrite it-- x minus a squared
minus 2yb plus b squared is
equal to minus 2yk
plus k squared.
Now what can we do?
Let's take all the y's
and the constants on one
side of the equation.
So if we move both of these
terms onto the right-hand
side, so we want to
add 2yb to both sides.
So we get x minus a squared is
equal to-- I'm moving both of
these terms to the
right-hand side.
So if we add 2yb to both sides
then we'll have a positive
2yb on the right hand side.
So 2yb, and then we'll have
that minus 2yk right there.
And then we're subtracting
b squared from both sides.
So it's minus b squared
plus k squared.
I just arbitrarily decided to
write whatever I transferred
from the left-hand side to the
right-hand side in magenta
just so maybe it makes
it a little bit clearer.
And let's see if we can
simplify this further.
And remember, just so you know
what I'm doing this whole time.
In the back of my mind I'm
trying to get it into the
format that I normally
associate with a parabola.
And I'll do it in the corner
here, just so you know
where the algebra's going.
I'm trying to get into a
format x minus a squared
is equal to y minus b.
Because if we have it in
this form, or actually ax.
Let me write that because I
went too far to the right.
A times x minus-- well,
actually I already used
the A so let me write x
minus-- I don't know.
I'll make up x minus--
I'll call that v squared.
I'm picking maybe v for
x value of the vertex.
I'm making up
variables on the fly.
A times x minus v squared
is equal to y minus b.
And you know, the actual
letters I chose don't matter.
But this is a general
form of a parabola.
And this is where
I'm trying to go.
If I can get this thing that
we're working on to this
form then we know we're
dealing with a parabola.
And then, we can actually
relate what we normally
associate with a parabola
to these terms up here.
And obviously, these
are different letters
than these letters.
And then we can try to figure
out-- if we have a parabola,
how do we figure out its
focus and is directrix.
But anyway, that was a bit
of an aside just so you
know where we're going.
So let's try to simplify
this a little bit more.
So we get--
[PHONE RINGING]
--my phone is ringing.
Let me silent it.
So we get x minus a squared
is equal to-- let's see.
If we factor out a 2 and
a y we get-- let me
factor out a y first.
We get 2b minus 2k times y.
And then I want to make
it minus some constant.
So this is a constant
right here.
This is one constant squared
plus another constant.
So I could make this
equal to minus-- let
me think about this.
This would be minus b
squared minus k squared.
If I expand this minus out
you would get minus b
squared plus k squared.
So this is the same
thing right there.
And let's see.
Can I factor out-- yeah,
I can factor out a 2.
The whole thing becomes x minus
a squared is equal to 2 times b
minus k times y minus-- and now
this is the difference of--
yeah, this is b plus
k times b minus k.
You might want to review
factoring polynomials if
that doesn't look familiar.
But this is b plus
k times b minus k.
And I want to do that because I
saw this b minus k out there so
that looked interesting to get
it on both terms right there.
Now let's see.
If we divide everything times--
let's divide everything by 1
over 2 b minus k because I just
want a y here, so I have some
coefficient in front of the y.
So let's divide everything
by 1 over 2 b minus k.
Let me do it down here
so I have some space.
1 over 2 b minus k times x
minus a squared is equal to--
I'm dividing this by 2 b
minus k, so that goes away.
So it's y minus-- so if I
divide this by 2 b minus k the
b minus k's cancel out and I'm
just left with b plus k over 2.
And I think I have gotten it
in the form that I wanted.
In this case, the a that
I wrote up here is now
1 over 2 b minus k.
This v is this a
that I did here.
The y is the y and then my
constant term is out here.
So I have hopefully shown to
you that the locus of all
points that are equidistant to
this point-- which is really
just an arbitrary point.
I said it's the point a,
b-- and some line, is
in fact, a parabola.
And that's one of the ways that
people define a parabola.
And we'll actually see soon
that when you actually change
this relation-- in this case,
we found that all of the points
that are equidistant to the
focus and the directrix.
If we changed that ratio, if we
find all of the points that are
1/2 as far away from the
directrix as the focus, we
start getting another
conic section.
If we said twice as far
we would get another
conic section.
So this is a very interesting
way of relating-- sometimes the
conic sections in the first
video I showed how they're all
related to cutting the
three-dimensional cone.
But they're also related in
this way and eventually I want
to relate this to the
three-dimensional cone so you
can see how it all
fits together.
Which is always the fun
thing about mathematics.
So this so far, all we've shown
to you is if we do take the
locus of all points that are
equidistant to a point and a
directrix that it
is a parabola.
Now, the interesting
thing to do is let's
say I have a parabola.
Let me give a general form.
And I'll try to use different
letters than I used up here.
So let's say I have a
parabola y minus--
let's call it y sub 1.
Where it's just a particular
point on the parabola.
Y minus y sub 1 or you could
call it some constant-- is
equal to-- let's call it, I
want to use a capital A just
because that tends to be--
I'll use a capital A and just
know that it's different
than this lowercase A.
Some capital A times
x minus x sub 1.
squared.
Whenever you see a y sub 1 or
an x sub 1, that means you're
actually dealing with
a constant term.
If you see just an x or y that
generally means that you're
dealing with a variable term.
So these are constants.
I could have put letters there.
I could have put a and b
there, but then that would've
gotten confused with that.
But let's see if we can relate
these letters because this is
something that we normally see.
And then, we want to find
the focus or the directrix
of a parabola like this.
How can we relate these to
these values right here?
How does k and a and b relate
to these right there?
So let's see if we
can set that up.
So if we just pattern
match that is A.
If we say x sub 1 is lowercase
a, actually that's a straight
up pattern match, so we can
already write that on the side.
x sub 1 is equal to a.
So whatever x value I have
here, this is also the x
value of the focus point.
Which makes sense because in
this case, we already learned
this in previous video.
But we learned that the vertex
of this parabola is the
point x sub 1 comma y sub 1.
Anyway, I don't want
to confuse you.
Actually, you know
what I'm going to do?
I don't want to go too far off
into this topic, and I think
this video has already
gotten long enough.
I will continue this
in the next video.
See you soon.